Avant que la vidéo ne commence,
j’ai une question à vous poser :
vous croyez VRAIMENT
que les gens ont lu
tous les livres dont ils parlent ?
Bien sûr que non.
— sinon on ne pourrait pas parler
de grand-chose.
Eh oui,
il y a vingt-quatre heures
dans une journée,
et il faut travailler,
manger,
dormir,
et sortir le chien.
Donc le secret de la culture générale,
ce n’est PAS
de lire des livres.
C’est quoi alors ?
Eh bien en fait,
il n’y a pas qu’un seul secret,
il y en a CINQ.
Les étudiants et les personnes
les plus cultivés,
les profs,
et les intellectuels
CONNAISSENT
ces cinq secrets,
mais ils se gardent bien
d’en parler…
Les gens qui les découvrent
réussissent à développer
RAPIDEMENT
et FACILEMENT
leur culture générale,
parce que leur rapport au savoir
A CHANGÉ.
Et une fois qu’ils APPLIQUENT
les cinq secrets,
ils comprennent toutes les références
des personnes cultivées ;
ils savent s’exprimer avec profondeur
sur n’importe quel sujet ;
ils brillent par leur culture
dans les conversations
et dans les débats ;
et ils ont le recul nécessaire
pour faire preuve d’esprit critique.
Ça vous intéresse ?
Eh bien je vous révèle
les cinq secrets,
et je vous explique
comment les appliquer
DÈS AUJOURD’HUI
pour vous cultiver
DIX FOIS PLUS RAPIDEMENT
SANS VOUS PRENDRE LA TÊTE.
Pour recevoir les cinq secrets,
inscrivez-vous simplement
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant en haut à droite
de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant sur celui
qui est dans la description
de la vidéo.
C’est l’histoire de dix secondes,
donc faites-le maintenant,
et vous pourrez découvrir le premier secret,
qui vous attendra bien au chaud
dans votre boîte mail
après avoir regardé cette vidéo.
Voilà voilà,
je vous ai dit
ce que je voulais vous dire.
Je vous laisse regarder la vidéo,
et moi je vais promener Haristote.
________________
PREMIÈRE RÉFÉRENCE : Vie de Zénon, Diogène
Laërce
Imaginez la scène : Zénon fait fouetter
un de ses esclaves qui a commis un vol.
Et comme le malheureux connaît un peu la
philosophie du maître, il se justifie en
lui disant « Mais c’était mon destin de
voler ! ». Et là Zénon lui répond : « C’est
aussi ton destin d’être fouetté ! ».
C’est une des nombreuses anecdotes que l’on
peut lire à propos de Zénon, le fondateur
du stoïcisme, dans les Vies et doctrines
des philosophes illustres de Diogène Laërce,
qui est un écrivain grec du début du IIIe
siècle.
Son livre, qui est la référence pour les
biographies des penseurs de l’Antiquité,
est également une référence incontournable
pour le stoïcisme, parce qu’il raconte
la création de cette école philosophique
à travers la biographie du fondateur.
Après la biographie de Zénon, Diogène Laërce
fait un exposé général des doctrines stoïciennes
qui est assez technique — et pour tout dire
peu éclairant.
Que retenir de la vie de Zénon ?
Tout d’abord, il ne faut pas le confondre
avec un autre Zénon.
Le fondateur du stoïcisme s’appelle Zénon
de Citium, une ville de l’île de Chypre
— et non pas Zénon d’Élée, un philosophe
présocratique qui vivait deux siècles plus
tôt.
Diogène raconte la légende de la « conversion
» de Zénon à la philosophie.
Appartenant à une famille de riches commerçants,
Zénon importe notamment un colorant pourpre
de Phénicie (le Liban actuel).
Un jour, il fait naufrage avec la cargaison
à Athènes.
Dans la capitale grecque, il entend un libraire
lire de la philosophie, et il lui demande
où sont les hommes qui enseignent cela.
Pile à ce moment, le philosophe Cratès passe
devant lui.
Le libraire dit alors à Zénon : « c’est
lui qu’il te faut suivre ». Zénon devient
le disciple de Cratès.
Il conclut : « En vérité, ce naufrage m’a
conduit à bon port.
»
Après, Zénon changera de maître, parce
qu’il n’aime pas l’impudeur des philosophes
cyniques (son premier maître, Cratès, en
était un).
Lorsqu’un oracle lui dit qu’il doit « fréquenter
les morts », Zénon comprend qu’il doit
lire les classiques.
En fait, il n’avait pas attendu ce conseil
pour s’y mettre, parce que son père lui
avait rapporté de ses voyages des ouvrages
d’auteurs de l’école socratique (donc
en réalité Zénon était déjà initié
à la philosophie avant de s’installer à
Athènes).
Il fonde son école sous un portique de l’Agora
(d’où le nom de l’école, le grec ancien
stoa signifiant « portique »), dans un des
endroits les plus populeux de la ville.
Ses disciples sont d’abord appelés « zénoniens
», parce que les « stoïciens » sont les
poètes qui exercent sous le Portique.
Comme Platon, comme Aristote, Zénon enseigne
selon la méthode dite « péripatéticienne
», c’est-à-dire qu’il parle en déambulant
(ça a notamment l’avantage de décourager
les simples curieux).
Un peu misanthrope, Zénon n’aime pas la
foule.
Et puis il faut le payer pour avoir le droit
de le suivre.
Maintenant, que retenir des idées de Zénon
?
À croire Diogène Laërce, Zénon enseigne
surtout par l’exemple.
Sa vie quasi ascétique donne une grande légitimité
morale à sa philosophie, et favorise son
expansion.
Plus précisément, Zénon incarne une valeur
fondamentale du stoïcisme, la résistance.
Il faut résister aux tentations, à la facilité,
à la souffrance.
Zénon est extrêmement endurant, au point
que les Athéniens emploient l’expression
proverbiale « plus endurant que Zénon ». Il
est également très frugal.
Il se contente d’un régime simple : petits
pains, miel, et un peu de vin.
Dans sa pièce Les Philosophes, le poète
grec Philémon se moque de Zénon en disant
qu’« il enseigne la faim ». Après, Diogène
Laërce montre que la vie de Zénon n’est
pas 100 % exemplaire.
Il lui arrive d’être ivre ; il n’est
pas insensible à l’argent (il en reçoit
beaucoup du roi de Macédoine Antigone Gonatas,
et il fait des investissements) ; et comme
d’autres philosophes, il aime les jeunes
garçons (ce qui, pour nous, relève de la
pédophilie) ; et enfin, pour parler sans
détour, il passe pour un donneur de leçons
de morale qui emmerde les gens.
Une autre dimension importante de l’enseignement
de Zénon, c’est la limitation de la parole.
À un jeune vantard, il dit : « La raison
pour laquelle nous avons deux oreilles, mais
seulement une bouche, c’est pour que nous
écoutions plus et que nous parlions moins
». Là aussi, Zénon montre l’exemple en
se taisant souvent et en s’exprimant surtout
de manière brève et sentencieuse, ce qui
contraste avec l’éloquence cultivée dans
les autres écoles philosophiques de l’époque.
Cette particularité s’explique par son
histoire personnelle : il est un demi-barbare
qui parle un grec à peine correct quand il
s’installe à Athènes.
Enfin, Diogène Laërce précise aussi — mais
ce n’est pas crucial — que Zénon aime
le savoir.
Il a une solide formation intellectuelle ; il
s’est entraîné à débattre ; et il est
prêt à payer cher pour qu’on lui apprenne
quelque chose.
En se fondant sur ce livre, on peut dire que
l’empreinte de Zénon sur le stoïcisme
est double.
Tout d’abord, il en fait une philosophique
pratique, c’est-à-dire qu’être stoïcien,
c’est adopter un certain mode de vie, se
conduire d’une certaine manière au quotidien.
Zénon impressionne tellement ses contemporains
par sa maîtrise de soi qu’Athènes lui
rend des honneurs publics à plusieurs reprises.
Et puis la seconde dimension de l’influence
du fondateur sur le stoïcisme, c’est que
le mode de vie stoïcien repose essentiellement
sur la modération, voire sur le refus du
plaisir.
C’est en partie une question de différenciation,
comme on dit en marketing : Zénon fonde son
école 5 ans après qu’Épicure a fondé
la sienne, et il le concurrence avec un message
plus radical, hostile à la relaxation.
________________
DEUXIÈME RÉFÉRENCE : Vie de Cléanthe,
Diogène Laërce
Je viens de vous parler de Zénon.
C’est un homme très austère, et ça semble
difficile d’aller plus loin en termes d’austérité.
Et pourtant son successeur à la tête de
l’école stoïcienne, Cléanthe, réussit
à le surpasser.
C’est encore Diogène Laërce qui nous raconte
l’essentiel à connaître sur ce philosophe
dans ses Vies et doctrines des philosophes
illustres.
Que retenir de la vie de Cléanthe ?
On ne sait pas grand chose de ses origines.
C’est un pugiliste (c’est-à-dire un boxeur)
qui est arrivé à Athènes avec 4 drachmes
en poche (autrement dit, il est très pauvre).
Étant donné sa pauvreté, il doit travailler
— beaucoup travailler.
Et il doit encore trouver le temps de se mettre
à la philosophie.
Concrètement, il puise de l’eau dans les
jardins la nuit, et il s’exerce au raisonnement
le jour.
Le seul moyen qu’il trouve pour prendre
en note les cours de Zénon est d’écrire
sur des tessons et des omoplates de bœufs.
Il est surnommé le « second Hercule » parce
qu’il est une force de la nature qui ne
s’arrête jamais de travailler.
Zénon dit à ce propos : « Cléanthe pourrait
nourrir un autre Cléanthe, s’il le voulait.
»
Malgré son acharnement au travail jour et
nuit (qui fait qu’il dort peu) — malgré
cela, il est en forme.
Les Athéniens pensent qu’il cache quelque
chose, donc ils lui font un procès ! Bien
sûr, il est acquitté, et les juges, impressionnés
par l’exemplarité de sa conduite, décident
de lui allouer une somme d’argent.
Si Cléanthe est une force de la nature, il
est en revanche peu doué intellectuellement,
et très lent, ce qui lui attire les moqueries
des autres élèves de Zénon.
Ça ne l’empêchera pas d’écrire pas
de mal de livres (même de « beaux livres
» selon Diogène Laërce), et surtout de
succéder contre toute attente à Zénon à
la tête de l’école stoïcienne.
Enfin, l’anecdote sur sa mort est révélatrice
de la dimension médicale de l’alimentation
dans l’Antiquité (dimension que nous avons
malheureusement en grande partie perdue).
Cléanthe est atteint d’une gingivite (une
inflammation localisée de la gencive).
Les médecins lui préconisent alors un jeûne
de 2 jours, et ça fonctionne : il guérit.
Enthousiaste, Cléanthe décide de continuer
le jeûne contre l’avis des médecins.
Et…
il meurt de faim.
Maintenant, que retenir des idées de Cléanthe
?
Comme Zénon, Cléanthe enseigne surtout par
l’exemple.
La 1ère clé de son exemple est bien sûr
le goût de l’effort, qui est une expression
particulière de la résistance valorisée
par Zénon.
Un jour, Cléanthe rencontre un Spartiate
qui lui dit que l’effort est un bien, et
ça rend Cléanthe heureux de voir qu’il
n’est pas le seul à avoir compris cela.
Mais son goût de l’effort est vraiment
radical : il dit qu’il préfère sa vie
à celle des riches, qu’il préfère travailler
la terre plutôt que de jouer à la balle.
Ainsi, la valeur suprême de l’effort est
liée à la vanité du divertissement.
La 2nde clé de son exemple est l’humilité.
Cléanthe ne se prend pas pour un surhomme
— c’est plutôt le contraire.
Il est timide — ce qui lui évite de commettre
des erreurs — et il s’insulte lui-même.
Son humilité implique d’être indifférent
à la critique.
Ainsi, il encaisse les moqueries des autres
disciples stoïciens, estimant que c’est
le prix à payer pour égaler la force morale
de Zénon.
Autre exemple intéressant : quand le poète
Sosithéos l’insulte devant tout le monde
au théâtre, Cléanthe reste de marbre ; impressionné
par cette réaction, les spectateurs l’applaudissent
et chassent le poète (mais Cléanthe accordera
son pardon au poète quand celui-ci éprouvera
du remords).
Enfin, comme pour le goût de l’effort,
l’humilité de Cléanthe est radicale dans
le sens où elle est liée à la condamnation
de la recherche de la gloire.
À un homme qui lui demande conseil pour son
fils, il répond un vers d’Euripide : « Silence,
silence, que la trace (de tes pas) soit légère.
»
Cléanthe a également transmis ses idées
à l’écrit, puisqu’il est — d’après
Diogène Laërce — l’auteur de pas mal
de livres.
Les hommes de l’Antiquité qui ont pu les
consulter disent que le style de Cléanthe
est très imagé, avec des allégories.
Le seul texte qui est arrivé jusqu’à nous
est l’Hymne à Zeus.
En gros, Cléanthe rend hommage à Zeus en
tant qu’auteur et régulateur de l’ordre
du monde auquel le stoïcien se soumet.
Chose intéressante : Cléanthe demande à
Zeus de permettre aux hommes de comprendre
comment il gouverne le monde, et il lui promet
qu’alors les hommes ne cesseront de le célébrer.
En conclusion, quelle est, d’après ce livre,
l’empreinte de Cléanthe sur le stoïcisme
?
En premier lieu, il alimente la culture stoïcienne
de la résistance en donnant un exemple radical
d’une vie entièrement consacrée à l’effort.
En second lieu, son Hymne à Zeus divinise
l’ordre du monde : le cours des choses,
tout ce qui survient est l’œuvre d’une
divinité qui gouverne avec clairvoyance et
bienveillance, c’est pourquoi les hommes
doivent aimer le destin en même temps qu’ils
s’y soumettent.
Par là, Cléanthe donne au stoïcisme un
côté religieux en personnifiant l’ordre
de la nature en un dieu suprême et personnel
auquel on s’adresse avec émotion, comme
à un père sauveur.
________________
TROISIÈME RÉFÉRENCE : Vie de Chrysippe,
Diogène Laërce
705 livres ! D’après Diogène Laërce (toujours
dans ses Vies et doctrines des philosophes
illustres), Chrysippe, le troisième dirigeant
de l’école stoïcienne, aurait écrit,
au total, plus de 705 livres ! Pas besoin
d’être polytechnicien pour comprendre qu’il
y a un loup.
Je vais vous donner la solution de ce mystère
dans les prochaines minutes, et je vais également
vous expliquer en quoi il est emblématique
de l’influence de Chrysippe dans le stoïcisme.
Que retenir de la vie de Chrysippe ?
Tout d’abord, c’est Chrysippe de Soles,
une cité grecque du sud de la Turquie actuelle.
Comme beaucoup des élèves des écoles philosophiques
de l’Antiquité, il est un fils de bonne
famille — mais on raconte qu’il se serait
mis à la philosophie parce que son héritage
a été saisi pour alimenter le trésor royal.
Après, ce n’est pas clair : est-ce qu’il
s’est mis à la philosophie par dépit ? Ou
bien est-ce que la perte de son héritage
(ce qui arrivera également à Sénèque,
le plus célèbre des philosophes stoïciens)
— est-ce que ce revers de fortune lui fait
comprendre qu’il doit s’entraîner à
résister à l’adversité ?
En tout cas, il devient le disciple de Cléanthe.
Deux de ses caractéristiques se manifestent
dès sa formation : il est doué pour les
idées et…
il est arrogant.
Il n’hésite pas à contester l’autorité
intellectuelle de Cléanthe (qui n’est pas
brillant intellectuellement, comme on l’a
vu).
Comme son maître, il est un bourreau de travail
— mais un travail intellectuel.
Il passe son temps à écrire — ce n’est
pas possible autrement, pour accoucher de
plus de 700 livres ! Il est très discipliné
: il couche 500 lignes chaque jour.
Bien évidemment, quand on écrit autant,
on écrit mal.
Diogène Laërce dit que le style de Chrysippe
est bâclé.
Et puis sur le fond, il se répète beaucoup
et pratique le bourrage de citations.
Ses sophismes sont médiocres.
Apollodore d’Athènes, un grammairien grec
du IIe siècle av.
J.-C., dit à ce propos : « Si on retire
les citations étrangères des livres de Chrysippe,
il ne restera plus que des feuilles blanches
». Chrysippe tient également des propos
controversés, comme de comparer les dieux
à des prostitués (ce qui était risqué,
à l’époque), de défendre l’inceste
et le cannibalisme.
Malgré cela, beaucoup de ses livres jouissent
d’une grande notoriété (en même temps,
dans le lot, il y en a forcément qui doivent
plaire !).
Sur le plan du mode de vie, Chrysippe n’est
pas du tout exemplaire comme Zénon et Cléanthe.
Il incarne certes la sagesse stoïcienne par
certains aspects : il est capable d’être
absolument impassible lorsque les esprits
s’échauffent ; ou encore, il pratiquait
la course à pied avant de se mettre sérieusement
à la philosophie (aujourd’hui, la course
à pied passe un peu pour un exercice stoïcien
parce que l’endurance est une forme de résistance).
Mais Chrysippe n’est pas du tout exemplaire
par d’autres aspects : il est loin d’être
aussi modéré que Zénon ; il n’a pas l’humilité
de Cléanthe, il est au contraire arrogant
(il prétend par exemple être le meilleur
maître de philosophie).
Enfin, il n’est pas fidèle à l’école
stoïcienne.
Comme d’autres disciples après la mort
de Zénon, il rompt avec le stoïcisme.
Il rejoint l’Académie (l’école fondée
par Platon) pendant un temps, avant de revenir
à l’école stoïcienne.
Il a 45 ans quand il succède à Cléanthe.
Maintenant, que retenir de ses idées ?
Il ne reste presque rien de ses 700 livres,
donc il est difficile de répondre à cette
question.
À croire certains auteurs ultérieurs, Chrysippe
serait l’inventeur de certaines images qui
illustrent la morale stoïcienne (comme la
comparaison de la vie avec une course qu’il
faut essayer de gagner avec fair-play).
D’après ce que dit Diogène Laërce, Chrysippe
n’a enrichi l’enseignement stoïcien ni
par ses discours ni par son exemple.
En revanche, il a bien laissé une empreinte
sur le stoïcisme : il l’a intellectualisé.
Les deux premiers fondateurs, Zénon et Cléanthe,
avaient certes une activité intellectuelle,
mais la manière de conduire leur existence
était une dimension essentielle de leur enseignement.
En comparaison, Chrysippe est plus un écrivain
qu’un sage.
D’ailleurs, d’après d’autres témoignages,
il redéfinit la philosophie comme la quête
du savoir rationnel.
________________
QUATRIÈME RÉFÉRENCE : Traité des devoirs,
Cicéron
Jules César, qui est dictateur perpétuel,
est assassiné en 44 avant J.-C.
Les sénateurs qui avaient préparé le coup
n’avaient pas prévenu Cicéron, parce qu’ils
savent qu’il est très anxieux.
Seulement, la réaction publique n’est pas
celle que les meurtriers avaient prévue.
Donc ils fuient Rome.
Cicéron, lui, se retire dans une de ses villas
pour voir comment les choses évoluent.
Il écrit à son fils un manuel de morale
qui le guidera toute sa vie.
Ce Traité des devoirs est une référence
incontournable du stoïcisme parce qu’il
transpose la morale stoïcienne au monde romain.
Cicéron n’est pas lui-même un stoïcien
— il est affilié à l’Académie de Platon
— mais son traité est un guide moral stoïcien.
Il dit au début du traité que ce sont les
stoïciens qu’il faut écouter pour connaître
les devoirs de l’homme.
Quelles sont les idées principales de cette
référence ?
Le traité est divisé en 3 livres : le premier
explique comment agir pour l’honneur ; le
deuxième comment agir pour atteindre un but
et obtenir un avantage ; et enfin, le troisième
dit comment résoudre le conflit entre l’honneur
et l’avantage.
Les deux premiers livres sont inspirés par
la philosophie du stoïcien Panétius de Rhodes,
qui est le fondateur de ce qu’on appelle
le « moyen » stoïcisme (qui désigne la
renaissance du stoïcisme à Rome au IIe siècle
avant J.-C) ; le troisième livre est davantage
l’œuvre de Cicéron lui-même.
Dans le premier livre, Cicéron met en lumière
le lien entre la vérité et la sagesse : il
faut connaître la vérité, se renseigner
efficacement pour être sage.
Il faut notamment connaître la nature afin,
ainsi que le préconisent les stoïciens,
de pouvoir vivre en accord avec elle.
Cicéron étend la thèse stoïcienne en ajoutant
que la nature inclut la nature humaine.
L’individu doit donc élaborer un idéal
de vertu qui s’aligne avec sa nature personnelle.
Plus généralement, en tant que membre d’une
communauté, il doit être utile à son prochain.
Cela demande de ne pas se laisser perturber,
y compris par le succès.
Cicéron reprend l’idée stoïcienne classique
selon laquelle il faut pratiquer la modération
en soumettant ses impulsions à la raison.
Mais la vertu n’empêche pas de chercher
à obtenir des avantages.
Dans le deuxième livre du traité, Cicéron
explique qu’il est nécessaire d’avoir
durablement bonne réputation afin de gagner
la confiance de ses semblables.
Et la meilleure manière d’y parvenir, c’est
de poursuivre un objectif noble avec intelligence
et honnêteté.
Mais quoi faire lorsque la vertu et l’avantage
sont en conflit ? Le point de départ de la
réponse de Cicéron est la nature sociale
de l’homme : le bien-être de l’individu
dépend de celui de son groupe ; par conséquent,
il se nuit à lui-même s’il nuit à son
prochain.
Cicéron illustre cette idée avec l’image
de la course de fond de Chrysippe : il faut
donner le meilleur de soi-même à la course
sans empêcher autrui de faire de même (par
exemple, en faisant un croche-pied).
La conclusion est qu’une action ne peut
pas être avantageuse sans être vertueuse
(puisque l’immoralité nuit à celui qui
est immoral).
Lorsque le bon choix n’est pas évident,
il faut examiner la moralité des conséquences
: si elles sont contraires à la vertu, alors
il faut renoncer à l’action.
Cicéron donne l’exemple du consul romain
Regulus.
Fait prisonnier par Carthage, non seulement
il conseille aux Romains de ne pas l’échanger
contre des Carthaginois qui ont une valeur
militaire supérieure à la sienne, et en
plus il tient sa promesse de revenir en tant
que prisonnier à Carthage après l’échec
des négociations.
Quelle est l’empreinte du Traité des devoirs
sur le stoïcisme ?
Comme je vous l’ai dit au début, ce traité
est emblématique de la transposition de la
morale stoïcienne au monde romain.
Après les premières heures du stoïcisme,
la ferveur initiale était retombée.
La doctrine était trop théorique pour les
Romains des deux derniers siècles avant J.-C.,
qui étaient avides de préceptes pratiques.
Ils voulaient en même temps une spiritualité
qui était absente du stoïcisme, mais qu’ils
trouvaient chez Platon et Aristote.
Deux philosophes, Panétius de Rhodes et son
disciple Posidonios, ont adapté le stoïcisme
aux mentalités.
Ils en ont fait une morale pratique, purgé
des détails dogmatiques.
Ils ont propagé l’habitude de la réflexion
morale et de l’examen de conscience.
Ce « moyen » stoïcisme pénètre — en
partie grâce à Cicéron — les divers milieux
de la société romaine.
Il devient même, sur le plan politique, un
foyer de résistance aux despotismes des empereurs,
en tant qu’école de pensée indépendante
refusant de pratiquer les cultes imposés
par le pouvoir.
________________
CINQUIÈME RÉFÉRENCE : De la brièveté
de la vie, Sénèque
La société a privilégié Sénèque — il
est né dans une famille aisée et influente
à Rome — mais la nature, elle, ne l’a
pas privilégié.
Sa santé est fragile.
Au début de la vingtaine, il tombe gravement
malade, au point qu’il doit repousser l’entame
de sa carrière politique.
Il part en Égypte, dont il pense que le climat
l’aidera à se rétablir.
Il en reviendra au bout de plusieurs années,
mais il aura des problèmes de santé toute
sa vie (il subit par exemple des crises d’étouffement
qui peuvent durer jusqu’à une heure).
Cela lui donne certainement une conscience
aigüe du temps qui passe.
Dans la jeunesse, avec un corps neuf, l’homme
vit comme s’il était éternel ; mais la
fragilité du corps qui se révèle avec les
années impose la conscience de la mortalité
: tout cela finira un jour.
Cet essai, De la brièveté de la vie, est
le livre de référence sur la condition humaine
dans le stoïcisme.
Et comme son titre l’indique, il traite
de la condition humaine à travers le prisme
du temps qui passe et de la conscience de
la mortalité.
Sénèque s’adresse à son beau-père Paulinus.
Le point de départ de son propos, c’est
que les hommes perdent leur temps dans d’illusoires
conquêtes ou de futiles loisirs.
Leur vie s’écoule comme un chemin qu’ils
parcourent sans le voir, perdus dans leurs
pensées.
C’est vrai pour les hommes les plus puissants
et pour les plus sages comme pour la masse
des hommes ordinaires.
Ils sont égaux sur ce point : tous, ils se
lamentent que la vie est trop courte — et
en cela, ils se trompent tous.
En réalité, la vie est bien assez longue.
Le problème réside dans l’emploi du temps
: c’est parce qu’ils gaspillent la vie
en avarice, en travaux, en inaction, en intrigues,
en conquêtes, en combats, etc. que les hommes
ont l’impression de manquer de temps.
Tout homme très occupé et mu par l’ambition
a en réalité une condition misérable ; c’est
pourquoi Sénèque recommande à son beau-père
Paulinus de ne pas se laisser absorber par
sa carrière publique.
La raison principale de ce gaspillage, c’est
que le temps n’est pas une ressource tangible
comme de la nourriture ou de l’argent.
« Ce qui abuse, écrit Sénèque, c’est
que le temps est chose impalpable, qui ne
frappe point les yeux : et l’on en tient
fort peu de compte ; je dirais presque, il
n’a aucun prix.
On le jette à pleines mains, il semble ne
rien coûter ».
Quelle est la solution ?
Il faut tout d’abord traiter son propre
temps comme la ressource qui a le plus de
valeur.
Rien, en dernière instance, ne vaut suffisamment
pour être échangé contre le temps.
Il est non seulement disponible en quantité
limitée, mais il n’est pas renouvelable.
Il faut dès lors l’économiser avec un
soin extrême.
Pour ce faire, il faut regarder le passé
avec recul, habiter le présent et ne pas
attendre, c’est-à-dire ne pas différer
de vivre.
Sénèque recommande de vivre chaque jour
comme toute sa vie afin de ne pas appréhender
le lendemain, et de se mettre ainsi à l’abri
du sort.
La conscience du temps qui passe et de notre
propre mortalité nous amène à un certain
mode de vie, celui du sage.
Sénèque considère que le sage est le seul
qui sache vraiment vivre, car il donne son
temps au seul vrai loisir.
Il défriche la vie pour les générations
suivantes comme les précédentes l’ont
fait pour lui.
En donnant ainsi, comme un ami, la richesse
de ses pensées par l’intermédiaire de
son œuvre, il ouvre les perspectives et le
temps ; en dessinant une vie qui ne périt
point, il est une porte vers l’immortalité.
La sagesse est donc, elle seule, à l’abri
du temps qui passe.
Ce livre n’est pas l’ouvrage de Sénèque
le plus influent dans le stoïcisme — mais
il a tout de même été influent à deux
titres.
En premier lieu, il fait prendre au courant
une direction athéiste et matérialiste (c’est
par exemple comme ça que Diderot qualifie
le stoïcisme dans L’Encyclopédie).
C’est facile à comprendre : si je dois
éviter de dépenser mon temps n’importe
comment, cela signifie que c’est l’ici
et maintenant, mon existence quotidienne dans
le monde matériel, qui a de la valeur — et
non pas une hypothétique vie après la mort.
On peut même voir dans cette vision de l’existence
une des racines de l’individualisme moderne.
En préservant son temps, on est centré sur
soi-même et on travaille à son bonheur individuel.
En second lieu, De la brièveté de la vie
marque également le stoïcisme sur le plan
de la forme.
Le style particulièrement clair de Sénèque
rend la lecture facile et agréable, ce qui
a bien sûr constitué un avantage considérable
pour diffuser les idées stoïciennes.
Si les occidentaux du début du XXIe siècle
s’intéressent encore au stoïcisme et lisent
encore Sénèque, c’est grâce à la clarté
de son style.
________________
SIXIÈME RÉFÉRENCE : De la vie heureuse,
Sénèque
Descartes passe pour le père de la pensée
scientifique moderne, mais il s’est également
intéressé à l’éthique (ou à la morale
si on veut), c’est-à-dire à la manière
dont les hommes doivent se conduire.
Et en la matière, l’essai de Sénèque
intitulé De la vie heureuse est une des références
de Descartes.
Il le commente d’ailleurs dans ses fameuses
lettres à la princesse allemande Élisabeth
de Bohême.
De la vie heureuse est une référence incontournable
dans le stoïcisme parce qu’il fournit la
définition du bonheur stoïcien (comme l’indique
le titre).
Les spécialistes de Sénèque disent aussi
que ce sont ses réflexions morales les plus
abouties.
Elles étaient destinées à son frère aîné,
l’homme politique romain Gallion.
Qu’en retenir, sur le fond ?
Sénèque définit le bonheur à partir de
l’idée fondamentale du stoïcisme, l’accord
de la volonté avec l’ordre de la nature.
On a tort d’envier à autrui l’éloquence,
la richesse, le réseau, et la puissance,
car ce sont des biens extérieurs qui sont
à la vie heureuse ce qu’un mur plaqué
de matériaux brillants est à une maison
d’un intérieur grossier.
Sénèque part de la situation de l’homme
ordinaire.
Cet homme n’a pas la recette de la vie heureuse.
Il désire le bonheur sans jamais se demander
en quoi il consiste.
Puisqu’il ne le définit pas, il part forcément
dans la mauvaise direction.
Et là, Sénèque nous met en garde contre
ce que les psychologues appellent la « preuve
sociale » : nous ne trouverons pas la vie
heureuse en nous contentant de faire comme
tout le monde.
« Rien, écrit Sénèque, n’a plus d’importance
que d’éviter de suivre, comme le font les
moutons, le troupeau de ceux qui nous précèdent,
nous dirigeant non pas où il faut aller,
mais où il va ». La multitude, la foule
est « le pire interprète de la vérité
». Malheureusement, quand il s’agit de
conduire son existence, chacun préfère adopter
les croyances par lesquelles il est contaminé
plutôt que d’exercer son jugement.
Or, on ne peut être heureux sans exercer
son jugement.
D’accord, mais comment être heureux précisément
?
Tout d’abord, il ne faut pas rechercher
le plaisir.
Sénèque critique la conception du bonheur
d’Épicure, auquel il refuse même le titre
de « sage ». Le problème avec le plaisir,
c’est que la quête de la jouissance conduit
l’homme à privilégier le corps aux dépens
de l’âme.
Or, cette préférence est incompatible avec
la vie heureuse, car le plaisir est instable,
tandis que le souverain bien se caractérise
par son immutabilité.
En cultivant le plaisir, on sacrifie sa liberté,
et les jouissances les plus grandes se changent
même en douleurs.
L’erreur fondamentale des épicuriens, c’est
de confondre le plaisir et la vertu.
Une chose agréable n’est pas forcément
morale.
Sénèque plaide donc pour sa chapelle : le
vrai bonheur est celui du sage stoïcien,
parce qu’il pratique le détachement, parce
qu’il cultive son indépendance morale à
l’égard du monde extérieur.
Les événements ne peuvent ni exalter ni
affliger l’homme véritablement heureux
; les coups de la Fortune l’atteignent seulement
comme les vagues se brisent sur les rochers.
Cet homme « obéit » à la nature tel un
soldat lié à son chef par un serment : il
n’est jamais frustré de rien, puisqu’il
ne veut que ce qui lui arrive.
La vie heureuse ne passe pas pour autant par
un ascétisme extrême.
Pour répondre à ceux qui lui reprochent
de philosopher tout en jouissant de son statut,
de sa richesse, et en soignant sa santé,
Sénèque développe la doctrine stoïcienne
des « préférables ». L’action parfaite
digne du sage n’est pas toujours possible
dans la réalité pratique, c’est pourquoi
il faut savoir se contenter de l’action
moyenne qui consiste à opérer un choix entre
des préférables.
La richesse n’est qu’un « préférable
» selon les circonstances.
Ainsi, la sagesse stoïcienne n’exclut pas
la richesse tant qu’on s’est enrichi honnêtement,
qu’on s’entraîne à redevenir pauvre,
qu’on est facilement généreux, et qu’on
ne place pas son cœur dans ses trésors ni
dans sa dignité d’homme riche.
Que dire concernant l’influence de ce livre
sur le stoïcisme ? Pour faire simple, il
règle le rapport du stoïcisme à l’ascétisme,
c’est-à-dire l’idéal et/ou le mode de
vie visant à satisfaire le moins possible
les instincts de la vie animale.
Beaucoup d’écoles philosophiques de l’Antiquité
tendaient vers l’ascétisme, mais la position
du stoïcisme restait à préciser.
Sénèque est dans une position particulière
pour répondre parce qu’il est l’homme
le plus riche de son temps (ça lui est d’ailleurs
très reproché, de donner des leçons de
morale et de prôner la résistance stoïcienne
du haut de son immense fortune).
Il est donc directement concerné par la question
— et en arrière-plan de cette question,
il y a l’enjeu de la cohérence entre les
paroles et les actes (le mode de vie de Sénèque
est-il compatible avec la philosophie qu’il
professe ?).
Sa réponse a 2 effets sur le stoïcisme :
1.
En prônant un certain rapport à la richesse
plutôt qu’en la condamnant, il contribue
à légitimer la participation des stoïciens
à la vie sociale.
Ils ne sont pas des sages vivant à l’écart
de la cité ; ils peuvent être des hommes
d’action.
En revanche, ils doivent profondément méditer
leur action.
2.
En condamnant le plaisir dans la première
partie de l’essai, Sénèque clarifie et
entérine la distinction entre le stoïcisme
et l’épicurisme.
Il existe de véritables points communs entre
les deux sagesses — ce qui explique que
des disciples passaient d’une école à
l’autre — il existe de véritables points
communs, mais la polémique de Sénèque en
fait deux visions du monde incompatibles.
________________
SEPTIÈME RÉFÉRENCE : Lettres à Lucilius,
Sénèque
À la fin de la vingtaine, je lisais une des
lettres de Sénèque à Lucilius chaque matin,
en buvant mon café.
L’idée derrière ce rituel, c’était
de me conditionner dès le début de la journée
pour aborder mon existence avec détachement.
C’était plutôt efficace.
Je ne suis plus ce rituel aujourd’hui parce
que ma routine matinale était devenue trop
compliquée — elle doit rester simple pour
durer.
Cette anecdote illustre ce qui fait des Lettres
à Lucilius une référence incontournable
pour le stoïcisme : c’est le meilleur exemple
d’application pratique de cette philosophie.
Érasme, un des plus célèbres humanistes
de la Renaissance, qui a traduit les œuvres
de Sénèque — Érasme aime les lettres
parce qu’elles offrent un reflet fidèle
d’une situation réelle.
Quelle est cette situation ?
Conseiller de l’empereur romain Néron après
en avoir été le précepteur, Sénèque tombe
en disgrâce en 62.
Il demande la permission de se retirer totalement
de la vie politique — en vain, car sa présence
est requise pour conserver l’appui des sénateurs.
Après qu’un complot contre l’empereur
échoue en 65, un des coupables affirme que
Sénèque était indirectement favorable à
l’entreprise.
Sénèque nie — mais il ne convainc pas
Néron, qui lui ordonne alors de mourir.
Sénèque écrit les Lettres à Lucilius pendant
les quelques mois qui précèdent son suicide
contraint.
Cette situation donne à sa parole une profondeur
inédite.
Il s’adresse à Lucilius, un ami de longue
date, un homme d’origine modeste qui s’est
élevé jusqu’aux plus hautes fonctions
politiques, pour l’encourager à mener une
vie philosophique selon les principes du stoïcisme.
Quelles sont les idées essentielles des Lettres
à Lucilius ?
On retrouve tout d’abord, sous une forme
simplifiée, la définition de la sagesse
stoïcienne par le détachement.
Le stoïcien place son bonheur dans ce qui
dépend de lui.
C’est sa raison qui lui permet de vivre
conformément à la nature.
La véritable liberté équivaut au consentement,
à la soumission à l’ordre naturel.
Ensuite, il y a 4 thèmes essentiels plus
précis dans les lettres :
1.
L’amitié — Sénèque reprend la distinction
d’Aristote entre l’amitié d’intérêt
et l’amitié authentique.
Comment reconnaître la seconde ? Par le niveau
d’engagement que la relation commande : on
est capable de suivre le vrai ami en exil,
de prendre des risques mortels pour lui.
Il faut donc bien choisir ses amis.
À un véritable ami, on fait autant confiance
qu’à soi-même.
On est totalement transparent avec lui, même
si l’usage veut qu’on garde certaines
choses pour soi.
Mais ne devient-on pas dépendant du véritable
ami ? S’il faut bien cultiver l’amitié
— puisqu’il est naturel d’avoir des
amis — il faut conserver son indépendance,
c’est-à-dire rester capable de se tenir
compagnie à soi-même.
2.
La vieillesse — Sénèque a pris conscience
de sa propre vieillesse en constatant celle
de la villa de campagne qu’il avait bâtie
de ses mains.
La dernière phase de la vie n’est pas la
pire, parce qu’on y est désormais libre
des passions, qui sont un peu les illusions
de la jeunesse : « Le grand charme de la
vie, écrit Sénèque, est à son déclin,
lorsqu’il n’est pas encore brutal ». Il
recommande de considérer chaque nuit comme
une petite mort.
Il donne même un rituel : au moment de se
coucher, se dire à soi-même avec satisfaction,
et même avec joie, qu’on a bien vécu jusque-là.
3.
La préparation à la mort — Sénèque reprend
la célèbre définition (déjà donnée par
Platon) de la philosophie comme préparation
à la mort.
Le sage stoïcien ne ressent pas l’angoisse
de la mort, car la fin est toujours proche
pour l’homme qui ne l’oublie pas ; c’est
pourquoi le temps qui passe ne change rien
à son rapport à la mort.
Et puis se préparer à mourir, c’est la
soumission la plus essentielle à l’ordre
des choses.
Enfin, il y a aussi un bénéfice psychologique
: l’homme conscient de sa mortalité jouit
bien plus de la vie (cet effet se produit
chez les gens qui apprennent que leurs jours
sont comptés à cause d’une maladie grave).
4.
La nécessité de pratiquer la philosophie
— Sénèque enjoint à Lucilius de faire
de la philosophie un entraînement quotidien.
La sagesse n’est pas dans les discours ; elle
se mesure dans l’action, tout particulièrement
dans la réaction aux accidents qui jonchent
l’existence.
Il faut agir selon les valeurs stoïciennes
de la modération (qui se traduit dans la
frugalité) et de la résistance (qui se manifeste
notamment dans le travail perpétuel).
Sénèque donne l’exemple en restant très
actif dans sa retraite.
Il travaille tard le soir et s’endort même
à la tâche.
Il suit le précepte stoïcien selon lequel
la mort doit nous surprendre en pleine action.
Il y a en tout 124 lettres, donc il y a encore
d’autres thèmes.
Par exemple, Sénèque évoque le rapport
au temps ou l’influence nocive de la foule.
Quelle est l’influence de ces lettres dans
le stoïcisme ?
Pour faire simple, elles font du stoïcisme
une philosophie pratique.
Sénèque méprise les « philosophes » qui
se contentent de jouer avec les mots ; la
véritable philosophie consiste à adopter
un mode de vie déterminé par des exercices
concrets.
Et la meilleure manière d’enseigner des
exercices concrets, c’est par l’exemple.
« Longue est la voie des préceptes ; courte
et infaillible, celle des exemples », écrit
Sénèque dans la Lettre 6.
Ce n’est pas un hasard si le stoïcisme
a resurgi au début du XXIe siècle, à l’ère
d’internet, comme un courant de développement
personnel.
Les auteurs américains de best-sellers qui
parlent des Lettres à Lucilius ne se plongent
pas dans Platon, Aristote, ou Kant — c’est
trop chiant à lire, et cela ne permet pas
d’améliorer concrètement l’existence.
Les Lettres à Lucilius sont si accessibles
que leur influence dépasse largement le stoïcisme
et la philosophie.
Sur le fond, elles ont beaucoup influencé
les intellectuels du Moyen Âge, où elles
étaient une des rares sources disponibles
sur le stoïcisme de l’Antiquité ; ensuite,
les idées éthiques de Sénèque ont beaucoup
influencé les humanistes de la Renaissance
et les philosophes des Lumières.
Sur la forme, la tonalité personnelle et
l’absence d’ordre du propos font des Lettres
à Lucilius un des principaux modèles du
genre moderne des essais (dont les Essais
de Montaigne sont le type accompli).
Bref, l​​es Lettres à Lucilius ont eu
une ÉNORME influence dans la culture occidentale.
C’est d’ailleurs un des livres de philosophie
les plus lus.
________________
HUITIÈME RÉFÉRENCE : Manuel, Épictète
Si l​​’étymologie grecque du nom « Épictète
», Epiktetos, signifie « serviteur », c’est
tout simplement parce qu’Épictète a commencé
dans la vie comme esclave.
On raconte qu’il avait un maître brutal,
voire cruel.
Un jour, ce maître veut essayer un instrument
de torture, et il se dit : « Tiens, si j’essayais
sur la jambe d’Épictète ». Un homme ordinaire
se sauverait en courant, mais Épictète,
lui, prévient son maître en souriant qu’il
va lui casser la jambe.
Et lorsque ça arrive, il ajoute simplement
« Je vous l’avais dit, n’est-ce pas ? ».
Cette anecdote est peut-être une légende,
mais elle montre que la résistance est vraiment
une valeur cardinale du stoïcisme.
Le Manuel d’Épictète est une des plus
célèbres sources du stoïcisme.
C’est un résumé, constitué par un disciple,
des cours que le philosophe donnait à Nicopolis
d’Épire (sur la côte centre-ouest de la
Grèce actuelle).
L’objectif était d’en faire un compagnon
permanent, un livre qu’on ait toujours sur
soi et qu’on puisse consulter en toute circonstance.
Simplicius, un philosophe des Ve-VIe siècles
après J.-C., dit du Manuel que « c’est
une arme de combat qu’il faut toujours avoir
à sa portée, et dont il faut que ceux qui
veulent bien vivre soient toujours prêts
à se servir ».
La pensée d’Épictète est également accessible
via ses Entretiens — mais cette source est
moins fiable, parce que le disciple (le même
qui a compilé les cours) a reconstitué les
dits entretiens de mémoire.
Certains estiment qu’ils les a imaginés…
Que retenir du Manuel d’Épictète ?
Ce sont des maximes s’adressant à un jeune
disciple qui n’est pas encore philosophe.
Le livre commence avec la formule culte du
détachement : « Il y a des choses qui dépendent
de nous ; il y en a d’autres qui n’en
dépendent pas.
»
Il faut plus précisément distinguer, d’une
part, les choses « libres » au sens où
elles dépendent de nous, où elles nous « appartiennent
» : ce sont notamment les jugements, les
tendances, les désirs, les aversions ; et
d’autre part les choses « serves », au
sens où elles ne dépendent pas de nous et
ne nous appartiennent pas vraiment : ce sont
notamment le corps, la richesse, la célébrité,
ou encore le pouvoir.
Pour Épictète, cette distinction est la
clé de la liberté et du bonheur.
Mais afin d’y arriver, il faut pratiquer
le détachement à l’égard de tout ce qui
ne relève pas exclusivement de l’âme.
Concrètement, pour se détacher d’une chose,
il faut la ramener mentalement à sa réalité
matérielle, la dépouiller de tous les sentiments
qu’on y a investis.
Épictète reprend également la thèse stoïcienne
classique de l’accord avec la nature : « Ne
demande pas, dit-il, que ce qui arrive arrive
comme tu veux.
Mais veuille que les choses arrivent comme
elles arrivent, et tu seras heureux.
» Autrement dit, une fois que l’on est
soumis au destin, on ne le subit plus, il
ne peut plus nous affecter.
Épictète reprend aussi la définition très
classique du philosophe par la maîtrise de
soi.
Enfin, il dispense pas mal de conseils de
sagesse à la fois précis et pratiques, comme
par exemple la nécessité de se lancer dans
un projet après l’avoir médité avec réalisme,
puis de s’y consacrer entièrement, sans
se disperser ; la nécessité de s’exprimer
avec parcimonie, en évitant la vulgarité
et en ménageant les sentiments des interlocuteurs
(conseil qui rappelle le laconisme de Zénon)
; ou encore la nécessité de limiter les
soins du corps à la plus stricte utilité.
Tous ces conseils sont intéressants, mais
ils ne sont pas particulièrement emblématiques
de la sagesse stoïcienne.
Le Manuel se termine avec une idée plus stoïcienne,
qui renvoie à l’exemplarité des deux premiers
fondateurs, Zénon et Cléanthe.
Pour Épictète, la philosophie n’est pas
une science, mais un mode de vie encadré
par des principes de sagesse.
Il précise même que L’APPLICATION des
maximes de sagesse est la PREMIÈRE étape
de la philosophie.
Quelle est l’importance de ce livre dans
le stoïcisme ?
Il est probablement le plus important tout
court.
Si on me demandait un seul livre à livre
pour découvrir le stoïcisme, c’est celui-ci
que je conseillerais — sans hésiter.
En fait, il porte bien son titre, parce que
c’est le seul véritable manuel — c’est-à-dire
un livre qui instruit le lecteur sur un sujet
en synthétisant l’essentiel — le Manuel
d’Épictète est le seul véritable manuel
du courant philosophique qu’est le stoïcisme.
Et contrairement à beaucoup de manuels de
philo, le propos est très accessible, très
clair, souvent concret, au point que cela
ressemble, pour nous, à ce qu’on appelle
du « développement personnel » (ce n’est
pas un hasard si le stoïcisme et le Manuel
d’Épictète sont revenus à la mode sur
internet).
Dans le détail des idées, l’empreinte
de ce livre sur le stoïcisme tient essentiellement
à la distinction de ce qui dépend de nous
et de ce qui ne dépend pas de nous.
C’est une méthode intellectuelle précise
pour atteindre l’indépendance émotionnelle.
Après, l’influence du Manuel d’Épictète
ne se limite pas au stoïcisme.
Ses idées sont notamment passées dans la
tradition chrétienne, où elles ont servi
à définir certains modes de vie de l’ascétisme
chrétien (comme celui des ermites du mont
Sinaï, ou encore la règle de saint Benoît,
un genre de constitution pour la vie monastique
rédigée au VIe siècle).
Le Manuel a également eu une influence littéraire.
Il a été traduit plusieurs fois en français
dès le XVIe siècle, et il a notamment fait
une profonde impression sur Pascal.
________________
NEUVIÈME RÉFÉRENCE : Pensées pour moi-même,
Marc-Aurèle
Le film Gladiator met en scène l’empereur
romain Marc Aurèle en prenant des libertés
avec la réalité historique.
Son fils Commode, qui lui a succédé, a bien
été un tyran — mais il n’a pas accédé
au pouvoir en assassinant son père.
Au contraire, ils ont exercé le pouvoir ensemble
pendant plusieurs années à la fin du règne
de Marc Aurèle.
De même, le film fait passer Marc Aurèle
pour un sage épris de justice sociale, alors
qu’il était un conservateur (en effet,
pour un stoïcien, la révolution est intérieure,
psychologique, tandis qu’à l’égard des
choses extérieures il faut se soumettre à
l’ordre naturel).
Ses Pensées pour moi-même, qui sont son
journal intime (qu’il a tenu en bonne partie
pendant ses campagnes militaires) — ce journal
intime est une référence incontournable
pour le stoïcisme parce qu’il est emblématique
de l’effort spirituel du philosophe stoïcien.
En tenant un journal intime, Marc Aurèle
dialogue avec lui-même (comme l’indique
le titre) afin d’examiner sa conduite et
d’imprégner son âme des principes et des
valeurs du stoïcisme.
Comme je vous l’ai dit à propos de Sénèque,
le stoïcien est un homme d’action, mais
il est crucial qu’il médite sur son action.
Quelles sont les idées essentielles des Pensées
pour moi-même ?
En premier lieu, elles présentent le stoïcisme
comme un mode de vie.
Marc Aurèle s’estime heureux de ne pas
être venu à la philosophie par un mauvais
chemin — celui de l’éloquence des sophistes,
de l’érudition, ou de l’étude de la
nature.
Pour autant, il reconnaît qu’il a du mal
à vivre comme un philosophe stoïcien.
Mais comment faire ? Marc Aurèle donne la
même réponse que les générations précédentes
de stoïciens : bien vivre consiste à agir
en accord avec la nature.
Cela demande notamment d’abandonner ses
croyances concernant le bien et le mal, car
elles sont de mauvais guides pour l’action.
Par exemple, la mort et la vie, la gloire
et l’obscurité, la douleur et le plaisir,
la richesse et la pauvreté, touchent autant
les bons et les méchants.
Elles ne sont donc ni des biens ni des maux.
Une autre idée essentielle est l’importance
de la justice.
Marc Aurèle affirme qu’il s’agit d’une
des exigences fondamentales de l’éthique
stoïcienne.
Or, le contenu de cette exigence dépend de
la définition de la justice.
Marc Aurèle reprend la conception socratique
de la justice comme harmonie des parties dans
le tout.
Il voit plus précisément l’univers comme
une cité dont tous les êtres rationnels
sont des concitoyens.
De même que la cité attend de ses citoyens
une certaine conduite, l’univers attend
des hommes qu’ils se comportent d’une
certaine manière.
Ainsi, l’homme doit se comporter de façon
à contribuer au bien-être de l’humanité
tout entière.
Marc Aurèle défend donc une forme d’altruisme,
c’est-à-dire une idée de la morale selon
laquelle bien agir consiste fondamentalement
à agir dans l’intérêt de nos semblables
(les autres êtres humains).
Concrètement, cet altruisme passe par des
actes simples : le stoïcien doit donner de
la nourriture à une personne affamée plutôt
que d’essayer de la convertir au stoïcisme
en la persuadant de résister à la faim.
Marc Aurèle estime que la propension de l’individu
à coopérer avec ses semblables pour le bien
de la communauté appartient à la nature
humaine.
On retrouve donc le refrain stoïcien de la
vie conforme à l’ordre de la nature.
Autre idée essentielle des Pensées pour
moi-même, Marc Aurèle insiste sur l’importance
de l’impassibilité, c’est-à-dire la
capacité à ne pas se laisser affecter.
C’est un autre mot pour parler du détachement,
de l’indépendance morale du sage.
L’importance de l’impassibilité se justifie
par une conception déterministe du monde.
Pour Marc Aurèle, le cours des choses n’est
pas le fruit du hasard : chaque événement
est l’effet d’une cause, laquelle est
elle-même l’effet d’une cause antérieure.
L’évolution du monde se décompose en une
chaîne de causalité.
Autrement dit, tout ce qui survient dans l’univers
survient par la nécessité.
Le stoïcisme de Marc Aurèle inscrit donc
l’homme dans un destin dont les événements
sont programmés, et donc prévisibles.
On n’en sait pas plus, dit Marc Aurèle,
en ayant observé la vie humaine pendant dix
mille ans que pendant quarante ans.
L’ordre des choses — auquel appartient
la nature humaine — l’ordre des choses
ne change pas, donc il est absurde de s’étonner
du cours des événements et de réagir émotionnellement.
Maintenant, quelle est l’influence des Pensées
pour moi-même sur le stoïcisme ?
Ce livre n’est pas original sur le plan
des idées.
Son influence tient essentiellement à la
pratique : c’est un exemple exceptionnel
de mise en application de la philosophie stoïcienne.
Autant Sénèque s’est vu reprocher de ne
pas faire ce qu’il dit (par exemple, il
était très occupé alors même qu’il recommandait
de ne pas s’immerger dans des projets ambitieux)
— autant le mode de vie de Sénèque paraissait
peu cohérent avec ses idées, autant la vie
de Marc Aurèle semble cohérente avec ses
discours.
Ses actes expriment la sagesse stoïcienne
: jeune adolescent, il décide de dormir à
même le sol malgré sa santé délicate ; devenu
empereur, il accepte de partager le pouvoir
; il met aux enchères ses propres biens pour
financer la défense de l’Empire romain
; il annule les dettes de simples citoyens
; il améliore plus généralement la condition
des pauvres et des esclaves ; et enfin, exemple
éloquent, il meurt de l’épidémie qui
décime son armée.
C’est ce que Nassim Nicholas Taleb appelle
le skin in the game : assumer soi-même le
risque que l’on fait prendre aux autres.
Bref, les Pensées pour moi-même sont le
témoignage le plus emblématique de l’accord
entre la pensée stoïcienne et la vie concrète.
Des hommes comme Zénon, Cléanthe, ou Épictète
ont certes été exemplaires, et ils ont certes
vécu en accord avec la philosophie stoïcienne
— mais quand on a l’Empire romain à gérer,
c’est une autre histoire.
Enfin, les Pensées pour moi-même ont également
popularisé l’exercice d’écriture qu’est
la tenue d’un journal intime (d’ailleurs,
cet exercice est parfois associé à la sagesse
stoïcienne dans l’imaginaire collectif).
Il a divers bénéfices (psychologiques, notamment),
mais le bénéfice mis en évidence par le
journal de Marc Aurèle, c’est de pouvoir
agir de manière réfléchie, de diriger consciemment
ses actes, de mener son existence, un peu
comme un général mène son armée.
Avec Marc Aurèle, le stoïcisme est on ne
peut plus une philosophie de l’action — mais
l’action obéit à la pensée, à la méditation.
________________
DIXIÈME RÉFÉRENCE : Consolation de la philosophie,
Boèce
En 525, le philosophe et homme politique latin
Boèce est arrêté, puis mis en prison à
Pavie, au nord de l’Italie.
Le roi des Ostrogoths Théodoric (dont Boèce
est l’intime en plus d’en être le conseiller)
— Théodoric l’accuse d’être impliqué
dans une conspiration.
Boèce clame son innocence — en vain.
Pour supporter sa chute de la meilleure condition
à la pire, il se raccroche à la culture
philosophique dont il a été nourri dès
l’enfance.
Il écrit donc la Consolation de la philosophie
en prison sans le secours d’aucun livre.
Cette référence n’est pas une œuvre strictement
stoïcienne.
Boèce évoque à plusieurs reprises le stoïcisme
et certains penseurs stoïciens, mais il ne
s’identifie pas lui-même comme un stoïcien.
Malgré cela, il y a plusieurs raisons qui
justifient de faire figurer la Consolation
de la philosophie dans le top 10 du stoïcisme.
Tout d’abord, les circonstances de la rédaction
de ce livre sont emblématiques d’une des
valeurs cardinales, si ce n’est de LA VALEUR
cardinale du stoïcisme : la résistance.
La situation de Boèce fait d’ailleurs penser
à celle de Sénèque, qui écrit les Lettres
à Lucilius pendant les quelques mois qui
précèdent son suicide contraint.
Autre raison qui justifie de relier la Consolation
de la philosophie au stoïcisme, les idées
essentielles sont évidemment d’inspiration
stoïcienne (Boèce s’inspire également
de Platon, mais dans une moindre mesure).
Dernière raison importante, enfin, ce livre
a contribué à la transmission des idées
stoïciennes de l’Antiquité romaine à
la période qui commence au IXe siècle, dite
« scolastique » parce que la production
intellectuelle est concentrée dans le système
académique lié à l’Église médiévale
(le mot « scolastique » vient du latin scholasticus,
qui désigne au Moyen Âge le chef d’une
école ecclésiastique).
Maintenant, que retenir de ce livre sur le
fond ?
Boèce personnifie la philosophie en une femme
à laquelle il se plaint et pose des questions.
Et en retour, elle lui tient un discours qui
vise à le consoler (d’où le titre du livre),
c’est-à-dire à soulager son profond chagrin.
Plus précisément, la philosophie veut rendre
Boèce plus résistant.
Lui qui a l’âme troublée par un grand
revers de fortune, il a l’impression que
les innocents souffrent les peines que méritent
les méchants, tandis que ceux-ci — les
méchants — font impunément tout ce qui
leur plaît.
L’inconstance de la fortune et le triomphe
du crime rendent donc nécessaire la résistance.
Seulement, la poésie n’est pas la solution.
Elle entretient la douleur et ne fait qu’accoutumer
le cœur aux maux qui le dévorent en exprimant
des sentiments frivoles qui étouffent la
raison.
C’est la philosophie qui donne à l’homme
les armes qui doivent le rendre invincible.
Et même plus il y a d’obstacles à vaincre,
plus il gagne en sagesse.
L’homme sage a d’autant plus besoin d’être
résistant qu’il est la cible naturelle
des méchants, ainsi que le montre l’histoire
de la philosophie.
Anaxagore, Socrate, Zénon, ou encore Sénèque
ont par exemple souffert de persécutions.
Mais la philosophie élève un rempart contre
la méchanceté, fût-elle celle d’un tyran.
L’homme qui sait supporter tous les événements
est toujours heureux.
Boèce retrouve la valeur de la résistance
stoïcienne.
Mais comment être résistant ? La femme qui
incarne la philosophie répond la même chose
que les stoïciens : il faut se soumettre
à l’ordre des choses.
Boèce affirme — à travers la voix de la
philosophie personnifiée — sa foi en un
ordre naturel immuable, créé par une intelligence
suprême et conduit par elle avec sagesse.
Cette intelligence suprême est Dieu.
Malgré cette providence, les hommes sont
sans cesse le jouet de la fortune.
Celle-ci peut rendre le même individu misérable
et heureux en moins d’une heure.
Si Boèce souffre, c’est donc parce qu’il
a oublié l’inconstance de la fortune.
Il a également méconnu le fait que les biens
appartiennent à la fortune, pas à l’individu.
Seulement, l’avidité des hommes est sans
limite — ils ne savent pas se contenter
des richesses et des dignités que Dieu leur
prodigue.
De ce point de vue, les revers de la fortune
ont un avantage : l’homme comprend que le
véritable bonheur ne réside pas dans les
richesses ou les dignités.
Alors où le véritable bonheur réside-t-il
? Dans la vertu.
Comme Sénèque, Boèce commence par réfuter
la conception ordinaire du bonheur.
Le bonheur ne réside pas dans les biens de
ce monde, car l’homme ne les possède jamais
ensemble — c’est pourquoi il souffre forcément
du manque.
Il y a même des effets pervers.
Par exemple, les richesses rendent les hommes
encore plus cupides et plus méchants.
De même, les hommes les plus puissants sont
les esclaves des passions qui les dévorent
intérieurement.
L’homme doit donc abandonner l’illusion
que les biens de la fortune le rendront heureux,
et simplement suivre ses besoins.
C’est la vertu qui le rendra heureux.
Pour cela, il faut acquérir la puissance
intérieure, qui consiste à régner sur soi-même
en dominant ses passions.
Boèce développe une idée qui me plaît
beaucoup : la distinction entre la puissance
intérieure et la puissance extérieure.
Un tyran a certes la puissance extérieure,
mais, écrit Boèce, « il est en proie à
mille tyrans intérieurs », en vertu de quoi
il est profondément malheureux.
En comparaison, l’homme sage vit peut-être
dans la misère, mais il a la puissance intérieure
: il règne sur lui-même ; il domine ses
passions ; de la sorte, il se possède lui-même,
si bien qu’il ne pourra jamais rien perdre,
et que rien ne pourra troubler la profonde
paix dont il jouit.
Boèce retrouve là la fameuse idée stoïcienne
du détachement.
Quelle influence cette référence a-t-elle
eu sur le stoïcisme ?
Sur le plan de l’histoire des idées, comme
je vous l’ai dit, la Consolation de la philosophie
de Boèce a contribué à transmettre et diffuser
les grandes idées stoïciennes aux philosophes
et théologiens de la période fertile du
Moyen Âge.
En effet, Boèce écrit à une période, du
Ve au IXe siècle — une période « vide
» sur le plan de la production intellectuelle.
Les invasions barbares empêchent le prolongement
de la culture classique, et la division de
l’Empire romain disperse les éléments
de cette culture.
Ainsi, la Consolation de la philosophie est
la seule œuvre philosophique notable de l’époque.
Ensuite, cette référence promeut la valeur
stoïcienne de la résistance par les circonstances
de sa rédaction.
Passer de la richesse et du pouvoir à la
prison est un des pires revers de fortune
qu’un homme peut connaître.
En liant les idées du stoïcisme à ce contexte
humain exceptionnel, la Consolation de la
philosophie donne à ces idées une grande
résonance.
Enfin, comme Boèce ne présente pas son discours
comme stoïcien alors que ce discours est
stoïcien en son fond, et qu’il le présente
comme le discours de la philosophie elle-même,
il contribue à assimiler — et on peut même
dire à réduire la philosophie au stoïcisme.
Son livre contribue donc à donner aux idées
stoïciennes une importance prépondérante
parmi les idées philosophiques MAIS SANS
les étiqueter comme stoïciennes.
Cette réduction de la philosophie à certaines
valeurs (stoïciennes, notamment) fait penser
à l’expression française « avec philosophie
» : « accepter son sort avec philosophie
», « prendre les choses avec philosophie
», ou encore « apprendre une nouvelle avec
philosophie », c’est faire preuve d’une
fermeté d’âme, d’une résistance morale
typiquement stoïcienne.
________________
Alors,
la vidéo vous a plu ?
J’espère que oui.
Si vous ne l’avez pas fait,
je vous rappelle
que vous pouvez découvrir
LES CINQ SECRETS
pour vous cultiver
DIX FOIS PLUS RAPIDEMENT
et SANS VOUS PRENDRE
LA TÊTE.
Inscrivez-vous simplement
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant en haut à droite
de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant sur celui
qui est dans la description
de la vidéo.
Croyez-moi :
faites-le,
et vous me remercierez.